Пелосі прибула на Тайвань -
як Китай реагує на візит політикині
США ліквідували лідера терористів -
що означає удар по «Аль-Каїді»
Москва прославляє свою армію -
що розповідає парад про Росію
В ефірі «heute journal»
з Ханною Ціммерман і Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Добрий вечір усім.
Останнє, що зараз потрібно світові -
це ще одна руйнівна військова ескалація,
цього разу - в Тихоокеанському регіоні.
Але саме цього всі й побоюються.
Усе це пов'язано з державний візитом,
якого б не мало бути,
який відбувається помітно й непомітно водночас,
і через який усім світом поширюються
тривожні екстрені новини.
Маленький урядовий літак США
приземлився сьогодні вдень за німецьким часом
у Тайвані.
Жодної червоної доріжки, жодних великих зібрань.
На кадрах майже нічого не видно.
Пані в рожевому костюмі -
це Ненсі Пелосі, спікерка Палати представників США,
третя людина в країні
після президента й віцепрезидентки.
Вона здійснює візит до країни,
яка не лише для США вже багато десятиліть
є делікатним дипломатичним питанням.
Тайвань у 265 разів менший за Китай,
він розташований лише за 160 км від Китаю
і відрізняється від нього,
адже на острові процвітає динамічна демократія.
Надзвичайно успішний економічно,
ліберальний, творчий -
Тайвань протиставляється політичній диктатурі Пекіну.
Саме тому він як сіль в оці для китайського лідера.
Для Китаю візит Пелосі - це гра з вогнем.
Пекін погрожує «цілеспрямованими військовими заходами».
Більше розповість Ульф Реллер.
Ненсі Пелосі проїжджає вулицями Тайбея
у супроводі великого службового кортежу.
Для Тайваню цей візит однієї з політичних лідерів США
символізує «гарантію існування»
в контексті складних відносин з Китаєм.
У повітрі відчувається напруга.
Цьому посприяли китайські військові,
які сьогодні зранку оприлюднили ці відео.
Народ і його солдати готові до бою.
Вони вигукують: «Я солдат,
я служу комуністичній партії,
я буду захищати свій народ».
Китайська армія готується до надзвичайної ситуації,
аж до вторгнення у Тайвань.
Наші винищувачі облетіли наш острів Тайвань,
щоб захистити суверенітет і нашу територію.
Увечері Тайвань висловив подяку Америці.
На будівлі висвічуються слова:
«Вітаємо, спікерко Пелосі».
Ще кілька днів тому тайванці були змушені
готуватися до надзвичайної ситуації -
нападу китайців та укриття в сховищах.
Страх війни став частиною повсякдення:
«Ми маємо бути готові до можливої війни».
Завтра президентка Тайваню
зустрінеться з Ненсі Пелосі.
Її візит вганяє відносини між великими державами
Китаєм і Америкою в глибоку кризу.
США вважають себе захисниками регіону,
який Китай називає своїм задвір'ям.
Китайці не забарилися з відповіддю.
Міністерство оборони оголосило 4-денні військові навчання,
які оточать Тайвань.
«Зрозуміло одне: відповідальність за це лежить на США.
Вони заплатять за спроби
підірвати суверенітет Китаю».
Конфлікт між Китаєм і Тайванем має криваву історію.
Під час громадянської війни
Мао боровся проти Чан Кайші.
Останній втік зі своїми військами від комуністів на Тайвань.
Президент Сі вважає себе наступником Мао,
а об'єднання з Тайванем - своєю історичною місією,
яку в разі потреби можна здійснити військовим втручанням.
Ми не виключатимемо застосування будь-яких засобів
і вважаємо можливими всі варіанти.
Ми хочемо переконатися,
що немає жодного зовнішнього впливу.
Біля берегів Тайваню Китай і США
вистерігають одне одного.
Це двобій великих держав.
Зараз у регіоні перебуває авіаносець «USS Ronald Reagan».
Ніхто не хоче послабити тут свій вплив.
Якщо Китай спровокує кризу
або загострення ситуації,
то це буде вина Пекіну.
Ми сподіваємося, що вони поводитимуться відповідально.
Після приземлення Ненсі Пелосі махає рукою -
це дружній жест у холодному регіоні.
США і Тайвань - союзники, але досить дивні.
У країнах немає жодних офіційних посольств.
Представництво США в Тайбеї
називається «Американський інститут».
Між державами немає жодних зустрічей,
хіба що скромні телефонні розмови.
Вони роблять усе, аби не розізлити Китай.
А зараз у Тайвань летить Ненсі Пелосі.
Ельмар Тевессен спостерігає за подіями з Вашингтону.
Добрий вечір, Ельмаре.
Наскільки небезпечний цей візит на думку Білого дому?
Небезпека може бути дуже великою.
Це пов’язано з тим, що місцеві експерти проаналізували,
які висновки зробив Пекін з війни в Україні.
Адже зараз можна бачити, яких зусиль докладає Росія,
щоб завоювати Україну.
Росії це не вдалося, і зараз вона має справу
з Україною, яку озброює Захід.
За результатами одного аналізу,
Китай міг дійти висновків,
що, мовляв, краще захопити Тайвань якнайраніше,
щоб запобігти конфлікту з противником,
який отримуватиме зброю від США та інших союзників.
Тому такий візит може стати для Китаю офіційним виправданням своїх дій -
у цьому й полягають занепокоєння.
Водночас є надія пояснити Китаю,
що у такий спосіб він зіпсує відносини
з іншими країнами, в цьому випадку зокрема й США.
Адже внаслідок військової ескалації
виникне другий фронт
поряд з війною в Україні,
а також посиляться зв'язки між Китаєм і Росією.
Це мало б масштабні економічні наслідки
для всіх країн світу,
адже цей регіон дуже важливий для торгівлі,
а так припинилася би будь-яка співпраця,
зокрема з важливих питань,
як-от боротьба зі змінами клімату чи пандеміями.
Тому зараз намагаються донести Китаю,
що такі дії не мали б жодної користі.
Поговорімо трохи про третю фігуру в політиці США.
Ненсі Пелосі вже довгий час критикує
уряд Китаю.
На цих кадрах можна побачити, що вже 1991 року
вона була на площі Тяньаньмень у Пекіні,
де розгортає прапор, щоб вшанувати
пам'ять жертв різанини, яка там відбулася.
Чи не тому вона зараз не змогла відмовитися
від візиту до Тайваню?
Це має велике значення,
але вона також відчуває підтримку
від політиків Демократичної та Республіканської партій.
Упродовж кількох місяців всі спостерігають за тим,
як Китай, принаймні створюючи таке враження,
готується до нападу на Тайвань.
Наприклад, у жовтні минулого року Китай
відправив 50 винищувачів
у нейтральну зону біля Тайваню.
Незабаром після цього Джо Байден
мав телефонну розмову із Сі Цзіньпінем.
Вони пообіцяли, що взаємно поважатимуть політику «одного» Китаю.
Але буквально за кілька днів після цього
Сі в Китаї виголосив палку промову
і дав зрозуміти, що врешті-решт Тайвань стане
частиною Китаю, і нікому не вдасться цьому завадити.
Тож припускають, що рано чи пізно
Китай скористайтеся можливістю
розпочати напад на Тайвань.
Уряд США сподівається,
що таке зіткнення не відбудеться зараз
просто тому, що одна політикиня відвідала Тайбей.
Ельмаре, щиро дякую.
Завтра відбудуться політичні зустрічі
Ненсі Пелосі в Тайвані,
а ми, звичайно, продовжимо обговорювати
цей конфлікт, що триває вже кілька десятиліть,
у програмі «heute journal up:date».
У США президент Джо Байден послав сигнал сили,
стоячи у незвичному місці - на балконі Блакитної кімнати
Білого дому, адже він досі хворий на COVID-19.
Це був також знак того, США не припинить
переслідувати тих, кого звинувачують
у найстрашніших терористичних актах,
як-от терактах 11 вересня,
а також того, що Америка
може завдати удару на відстані.
Аймана Аль-Завахірі, лідера
терористичної мережі «Аль-Каїда»,
було ліквідовано у Кабулі
завдяки американському бойовому дронові
з дистанційним керуванням.
Подробиці - в сюжеті Клаудії Бейтс.
«Most wanted» (букв. «найбільш розшукуваний») -
Плакат ФБР про найбільш розшукуваного терориста
вже оновлено: «deceased» - мертвий.
Стовпи диму над будинком у Кабулі свідчать про ранковий удар у неділю.
Удар по будинку, в якому, за даними розвідки США,
переховувався глава терористичної організації «Аль-Каїда»
разом із дружиною та дочкою,
було завдано у неділю.
Він ніколи не виходив з дому,
але постійно перебував на балконі,
де його зрештою й обстріляли двома ракетами з безпілотника.
Спецслужби США планували операцію протягом шести місяців
за погодженням з президентом Байденом.
Правосуддя відбулося,
цього лідера терористів більше немає.
Людство більше не повинно боятися
цього диявольського вбивці.
Сполучені Штати продовжують демонструвати рішучість
і нашу здатність захищати американський народ від тих,
хто прагне завдати нам шкоди.
Айман аль-Завахірі був правою рукою
колишнього лідера «Аль-Каїди» Осами бен Ладена
та ініціатором руйнівних терористичних атак
11 вересня 2001 року.
Він зіграв ключову роль
у нападі на військовий корабель USS Cole у 2000 році,
під час якого загинуло 17 солдатів,
а також у нападах на посольства США в Кенії та Танзанії в 1998 році,
де загинуло понад 200 осіб.
Незалежно від того, скільки часу це займе і де ви сховаєтеся,
якщо ви будете погрожувати нашому народу,
ми знайдемо і знешкодимо вас.
Навіть після хаотичного виведення
американських військ з Афганістану
президент Байден, незважаючи на будь-яку критику, наполягав,
що США можуть продовжувати антитерористичну боротьбу віддалено,
без солдатів у країні.
Експерти вже змогли переконатися в цьому.
Розвідці вдалося отримати
достовірну інформацію щодо місця перебування Аль-Завахірі
та знешкодити його, не завдавши нікому шкоди.
Це було добре сплановане
та успішно зреалізоване знищення терориста.
Аль-Завахірі створив регіональні відділення
«Аль-Каїди» в багатьох країнах,
які він не міг контролювати.
Удар має більше символічний,
ніж оперативний характер,
тому що справжньою загрозою в Афганістані,
якщо ми говоримо про міжнародний екстремізм,
є афганський підрозділ ІД «Хорасан».
Керівництво радикального ісламістського руху «Талібан»
повинно було знати,
що аль-Завахірі перебуває в Кабулі.
За даними США, будинок, в якому він перебував,
належав близькому соратнику
міністра внутрішніх справ Афганістану Хаккані,
який і сам очолює терористичну мережу.
«Талібан» пообіцяв припинити співпрацю з «Аль-Каїдою»
після того, як США виведуть свої війська.
Зараз Сполучені Штати бачать, що угода порушена.
На черзі - огляд новин з Ханною.
Верховний суд Росії
визнав український полк «Азов» терористичною організацією.
Бійцям полку,
які зараз перебувають у російському полоні
загрожують роки ув'язнення.
Бійці «Азову» довго тримали оборону
на металургійному заводі в портовому місті Маріуполь.
Полк викликає суперечки через своє ультраправе коріння.
Через нестачу газу уряд Іспанії
вирішив вжити жорстких заходів для економії енергії.
Невдовзі у всіх громадських будівлях
обмежать температуру кондиціонерів.
Те саме стосується готелів, офісів і магазинів.
Охолоджувати приміщення дозволено лише до 27°C,
а взимку максимальна температура повинна становити 19°C.
Крім того, світло увечері має бути вимкненим.
Це стосується, наприклад, вітрин у роздрібній торгівлі
та визначних пам'яток культури.
Консервативна опозиція вже оголосила про опір таким заходам.
У Франції наближається скасування абонентської плати
за суспільне мовлення.
Після Національних зборів
Сенат у першому читанні також ухвалив урядовий законопроєкт,
згідно з яким
суспільне мовлення фінансуватиметься за рахунок ПДВ.
Однак Сенат хоче обмежити цю постанову до 2024 року
і закликає до того часу розробити ефективнішу реформу.
На думку уряду,
скасування абонентської плати стане полегшенням для громадян.
Сьогодні у Вищому окружному суді Франкфурта розпочався процес
над підозрюваним правим екстремістом.
Федеральна прокуратура звинувачує 20-річного Марвіна Е.
у підготовці серйозного акту насильства, який загрожує державі.
Зазначається, що обвинувачений планував напади
з використанням вибухових пристроїв і вогнепальної зброї
та порушував Закон про зброю та вибухові речовини.
Його також звинувачують у спробі
створити терористичну організацію «Atomwaffen Division».
Сьогодні в колишньому концтаборі «Освенцим»
вшанували пам’ять сотень тисяч сінті та ромів,
які були вбиті націонал-соціалістами.
Голова Центральної ради німецьких сінті та ромів Романі Розе
закликав до активного протистояння ромофобії,
яка знову набирає сили.
Президент Федеральної ради Бодо Рамелов
говорив про «такий собі негласний апартеїд»,
через який члени найбільшої меншини Європи
стають маргіналізованою групою в багатьох сферах життя.
Війна Росії проти України,
про яку ми тут постійно говоримо і переймаємося,
дивним чином відсутня в самій Росії.
Російські ЗМІ розповідають свою героїчну історію «спецоперації»,
в якій згадки про українські жертви та звірства над мирним населенням
відсутні так само,
як і слово «війна».
У соціальних мережах Кремль уміло
апелює до емоцій і наче непомітно впливає на користувачів.
На думку західних вчених,
більшість людей у Росії майже не намагається
порівнювати повідомлення ЗМІ з реальністю.
Інші ж намагаються викинути з голови і
«відключити» для себе все негативне.
Сьогодні Росія святкує День Повітряно-десантних військ (ПДВ).
Детальніше - Фібі Ґаа з Москви.
Ірина хоче, щоб її сини в майбутньому пішли в армію.
За її словами, Росія зараз переживає мирні часи,
окрім цієї військової операції.
У будь-якому разі я вважаю,
що Україна нам не ворог,
але чомусь склалася така ситуація, щось там не поділили.
Сьогодні повітряно-десантні війська Росії
дуже весело святкують їхнє свято.
Як видно, жорстока боротьба в Україні
не псує настрою.
Настрій святковий.
Моя дружина з України,
тому це дуже близько і боляче для нас.
Але я ще раз кажу,
там не воюють з українським народом,
там відбувається військова спецоперація
проти українського режиму.
Це є офіційним наративом,
який постійно повторюють Путін і пропаганда.
Значна частина населення вірить у ці наративи,
тому не зважає на війну в Україні, ігнорує цю тему
та насолоджується літом.
Те, що російські солдати вбивають і гинуть в Україні,
здається, не грає ролі в повсякденному житті Москви.
Що залежить від мене в цій ситуації?
Нічого, так само, як і від вас.
Ми можемо лише спостерігати,
чекати результату і змін.
Я чекаю на перемогу.
Росіяни демонструють спокій і легку невимушеність
в той час, як державне керівництво руйнує сусідню країну
і погоджується жити під санкціями,
які ставлять під загрозу їхнє власне майбутнє.
У незалежному дослідницькому інституті «Левада»
намагаються знайти відповідь на показну байдужість.
Хто винен у жертвах і руйнаціях, запитали ми?
Перше місце посіло НАТО.
На другому місці, з великим відставанням, - Україна,
а Росія ні в чому не винна.
Так людина звільняє себе від думки,
що йде братовбивча війна.
Будь-яка критика військових дій може бути покарана.
Державну репресивну машину Росії
неможливо не помітити.
У липні Марина Овсяннікова назвала Путіна вбивцею.
Через те, що вона вигукувала антивоєнні гасла
та розміщувала пости в соцмережах,
проти неї відкрито кілька судових справ.
Багато друзів дзвонять мені і кажуть:
«Боже, для чого ти це зробила?
Вони тебе розтопчуть,
знищать, уб'ють».
Ми не підтримуємо цю війну,
але ми вважаємо, що зараз краще мовчати, тому ми притихли
і чекаємо, чим все це закінчиться.
Чи то «зручне» незнання правди, чи тривожне очікування,
але поки в Україні тривають бої,
у столиці Росії люди вирішили віддатися на волю випадку
і жити, як доля вирішить.
Досить вражаючий погляд Росії на світ.
А зараз знову Ханна
про виклики сьогодення.
Ситуація стає все складнішою.
Компаніям стає все важче знайти кваліфікованих працівників.
Згідно з опитуванням Інституту економічних досліджень «ifo»,
майже кожна друга компанія
скаржиться на нестачу кваліфікованих працівників.
І це новий рекорд.
Стефані Баррет:
На які саме галузі це найбільше впливає?
Проблема нестачі кваліфікованих кадрів поширюється
фактично на всі галузі.
Але під час детального розгляду
відмінності досить великі.
Найбільше постраждала сфера послуг, особливо
працівники з непостійною зайнятістю,
як-от податкові консультанти й аудитори.
Галузі роздрібної торгівлі й будівництва
вже давно скаржаться на нестачу персоналу.
Найкраще становище в хімічній та
фармацевтичній промисловості.
Скрізь відчувається брак кадрів.
За даними Асоціації німецьких ремісників, у їхній сфері
не вистачає чверті мільйона кваліфікованих працівників.
Щороку вакантними залишаються до 20 тисяч навчальних місць.
Дедалі більше компаній змушені скорочувати свій бізнес,
оскільки вони не можуть знайти достатньо персоналу.
Спричинена коронавірусом криза прискорила цю тенденцію,
оскільки кваліфіковані працівники,
які залишили місце роботи або були звільнені,
не повертаються на старі місця роботи.
Особливо це стосується готельно-ресторанного бізнесу,
а також авіаційної індустрії -
в аеропортах Німеччини подорожуючі вже відчули це на собі.
У чому причина нестачі кваліфікованих кадрів?
Причини різні,
хоча зараз після пандемії дедалі більше людей знову працюють,
зокрема й люди пенсійного віку,
однак цього недостатньо.
Це пов’язано насамперед з демографічними змінами.
Людей, які виходять на пенсію, значно більше,
ніж тих, хто зайняв би їхнє місце.
Ранній вихід на пенсію, наприклад, у 63 роки
також збільшив розрив у кваліфікованій робочій силі.
Тенденція до навчання в університетах також збільшила
нестачу кваліфікованих працівників.
Зацікавити молодь обирати практично орієнтовані професії,
професії в галузі ремесла,
поки що не зовсім вдається.
Імідж і, звичайно, оплата праця
після отримання диплома університету більш привабливі.
Стефані, дякую за репортаж з Франкфурта.
Згідно з даними Інституту Роберта Коха RKI,
через 3 місяці після виявлення першого
випадку зараження мавпячою віспою у Німеччині
вперше нею заразилося двоє підлітків.
Загалом, RKI зареєстрував 2724 випадки зараження.
Інфікування відбувається переважно серед чоловіків
під час статевого контакту.
Голова Всесвітньої медичної асоціації Монтґомері
в інтерв'ю редакційній мережі RND
закликав до покращення інформування населення
щодо вірусу.
Нещодавно в Європі була схвалена вакцина
проти мавпячої віспи.
Хороші новини щодо лісових пожеж
на Сході Німеччині.
За даними пожежної бригади,
пожежу на Півдні Бранденбурга вдалося загасити.
Вона спалахнула минулого тижня
і швидко поширилася приблизно на 800 гектарів.
Натомість у Саксонській Швейцарії ситуація все ще напружена.
Там тривають роботи з гасіння пожежі.
Померла співзасновниця
Асоціації захисту людей похилого віку
та партії «Сіра пантера» Труде Унру.
Як стало відомо, колишня депутатка  Бундестаґу
відійшла у вічність у листопаді минулого року
у віці 96 років.
З 1970-х років вона зробила собі ім’я
як борець за права людей похилого віку.
Протягом 3 років вона була безпартійною кандидаткою,
обраною за списками від Зелених у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії,
та боролася, зокрема, за підвищення мінімальної пенсії.
Напевно, ще можна мріяти.
Особливо в ці часи.
І те, що дехто
зневажливо назве утопічною маячнею,
зараз важливіше, ніж коли-небудь раніше.
У ці часи.
Наша кінокритикиня Забіна Шульц
перенесе нас у Синайську пустелю -
у цей неймовірний біблійний пейзаж.
До двох чоловіків і верблюда.
Німецька кінокомедія,
яка розповідає про дивовижну силу
несподіваних зустрічей.
Саме те, що нам зараз потрібно.
Це цікава подорож через Синайську пустелю.
Історія дивовижної дружби.
Все починається в Єрусалимі.
Бен щойно прилетів з Нью-Йорку.
В ультраортодоксальному районі Меа Шеарім
його мали познайомити з обраницею.
Але потім він вбачає шанс
уникнути шлюбу за домовленістю.
Мені потрібен хтось для Александрії.
Ми найстаріша єврейська громада в діаспорі.
А зараз їх всього дев'ять.
І якщо до Песаха не знайти десяту людину,
все перепаде єгиптянам.
Я можу піти.
Лише шість днів до єврейського свята Песах.
Час збігає.
Після запізнення на літак
дещо наївний Бен вирішує скористатися
сухопутним шляхом.
Ласкаво просимо до Єгипту.
Я пропустив щось у новинах?
Не всі араби в автобусі в захваті від Бена.
Для нього поїздка скінчилась посеред пустелі.
Але як поєднати єврейські вірування та обряди
з архаїчними законами пустелі?
Головний актор Люзер Тверскі - щаслива знахідка для фільму,
оскільки він також був експертом
щодо питань єврейської релігії.
Я сам виріс у хасидській общині у Брукліні,
яку залишив у віці 22 років.
Тому я міг проконсультувати знімальну команду.
Одяг, який я ношу у фільмі - мій власний,
навіть капелюх.
Щоб вчасно дістатися до Александрії,
останньою надією Бена стає сварливий бедуїн.
Я тебе підвезу, але спочатку мені потрібно знайти
свого верблюда.
Але потім все сталось не так як гадалось,
і це стосується не лише несправності в автомобілі.
Релігії та забобони зіштовхуються:
образи ворогуючих у регіоні сторін.
Є деякі з нас, хто взагалі не хоче Ізраїлю,
доки не прийде Месія.
А бомби в секторі Гази?
Це не ми, у моїй мові немає навіть слова
ракета чи винищувач.
Так хто це зробив? Швейцарія?
Але чим краще вони пізнають один одного,
тим ближчими стають
і більше поважають один одного.
Сьогодні твоєму Богові подобається мій хліб.
Так, сьогодні він кошерний, бо я допомагав готувати.
Бедуїни кажуть, що коли з тобою хтось їсть,
тоді немає місця для сварки, є місце для дружби.
Загалом ми переконалися,
що звичайні прості люди,
таксисти з однієї чи іншої сторони,
не мають проблем один з одним.
І це теж універсально: якщо люди зустрічаються
і ставляться один до одного по-людськи,
проблеми виникають рідко.
А якщо в колодязі немає води?
Тоді це наша «таємна вечеря».
Те, як пригоди в пустелі завершуються дружбою,
яка вище будь-якої віри,
зображено у цьому фільмі через
фантазійний шарм і веселе підморгування.
«Не зовсім кошерний» -
це божественна, чудова комедія.
Смішна, глибока і сповнена надії.
Фільм «Не зовсім кошерний»
післязавтра з'явиться у кінотеатрах.
Наскільки нескінченно важливими є прості зустрічі,
ніколи не стане зайвим показувати це
особливо в такому регіоні,
як Близький Схід,
де людям стає все важче мати такі зустрічі
через дії верхівки.
Одразу після випуску новин буде спеціальний репортаж.
Колеги з команди «37 Grad» працювали над ним
цілий рік.
Це документальний фільм, який варто, а то й необхідно подивитися.
«Ich bin viele / Мене багато» - така назва документального фільму,
який показує,
як відчуває себе людина,
всередині якої «живуть» 12 особистостей.
Прямо зараз на ZDF.
А згодом - випуск «heute journal up:date»
о 00:15 з Крістофером Верманом.
Гарного вечора і побачимось наступного разу.
Добрий вечір, зараз триває третя хвиля спеки.
І подібно до попередніх хвиль
пік спеки триватиме не довше 1-2 днів.
Звідки ж прийшла хвиля спеки?
Звичайно, знову ж таки з Піренейського півострова.
Пік хвилі спеки в Німеччині
буде в четверг.
Найближча ніч буде досить свіжою,
принаймні на підгір'ї Альп і у Верхньому Пфальці
температура впаде до 12°С.
У регіоні Рейн-Майн температура впаде до 19°С.
Ніч буде переважно ясною, на півночі Німеччини
невелике скупчення хмар, так само буде і завтра вдень.
Світитиме сонце, небо буде ясним.
На півночі Німеччини купчасті хмари
створюватимуть невелику тінь, опадів не очікується.
А ось тут ставатиме спекотніше:
завтра температура підійматиметься до 30-36°С.
Тільки на Північному морі буде менш спекотно 28-29°С.
В четвер буде пік спеки:
біля Лаузіца в напрямку Бранденбурга,
а також у Саксонії-Ангальт
і на Середньому та Верхньому Рейні
температура становитиме 38-39°С.
Хвиля спеки швидко мине,
температура нормалізується
вже на цих вихідних.
На узбережжях вона становитиме 20-21°С,
на півдні Німеччини 25-29°С,
що вже не так спекотно.
Спека не відступить без наслідків -
попереду сильні грози:
у п'ятницю гроза пройде в центрі Альп,
а в суботу на підгір'ї Альп.
Гарного вечора.